react router is extremely common to use
in react projects john smilga has
created many popular courses and now he
will teach you about react router what's
up everybody this is john from coding
addict and welcome to react router 6
tutorial video
now if you're not familiar with react
router
it's an awesome library that makes
building single page applications with
react a breeze
so unlike the traditional multi-page
applications where we run back to the
server every time we navigate to the
page with single page applications we
load
all of our html and javascript in one
page
more specifically in one div
and handle the rest of the logic with
the help of javascript
and as a result our project
get that snappy app like feel
now since react does not have built-in
routing solutions
that's why we reach for extra library
and by far the most popular option out
there is react router
version 6 is just the latest and
greatest option
with bunch of cool new features and
custom hooks so if we take a look at the
typical multi-page application
we'll notice that every time we navigate
to a page we trigger
full page refresh because browser needs
to run back to the server
get the contents
and then display them
unlike the react application
where changes happen instantly notice we
get this snappy response and the reason
for that is because we have single page
application
so like i said we have single page
more specifically we have
single div with an id of root
and then
all the changes get handled by
javascript
and therefore the contents of the page
load instantly without the full page
refresh
in order to follow along you'll need a
star and it's located in this repo so
look for my github and then more
specifically repo by the name of react
router 6 tutorial
then i'm gonna go for download option
after that i'm gonna navigate to my
downloads crack it open
drag and drop so now it's sitting
on my desktop then
i think i'll rename it i'm just going to
go with react router
after that i want to open up
visual studio code
drag and drop
set right away
side by side
with the
browser and then we want to open up the
integrated terminal
and we want to go with npm install
and right away
npm start and essentially this is a
boilerplate
react application
effectively i created with create react
app and here you'll just find some
useful resources
so we don't have to type out some
boilerplate code so in the source
there's a final folder
where you'll find complete application
so if you ever need to
reference the code that i type in the
videos you can find it over there
we also have pages folder
and you'll see in the following videos
why we have it there effectively it's
just a bunch of react components and
again we'll talk about them
in a few videos after that we have
app.js where we just have a heading 2
with this text data.js also something
that we'll implement a little bit later
index.css with all of the styling
now there's not much to it but still i
added a little bit of styling here and
of course index.js and also in the root
you'll find readme
where
i
wrote down all the steps we're going to
take throughout this project
and if you see in the browser react
router 6 tutorial then we're in good
shape and we can start exploring react
router 6. okay and before we start
typing away let me just mention a few
things first if you ever want to run the
complete application so not just
reference the code in the final one but
if you actually want to see some feature
in action
just go to index.js
and swap
the app.js files so essentially you want
to get the address from the final folder
so like i said final folder is where
you'll find complete application
and in here
there's also a app.js so just go to
index.js get the app.js from the final
folder and i already added the code you
just need to comment the first one out
and uncomment the last one
then if you ever need a reference
to
official documentation i left it in read
me a link so if you click on this link
you'll navigate
to the official docs of react router 6.
and when it comes to install for your
own projects the command you're looking
for is npm install react router dom at
6.
now
of course i already installed this
package
in this project but just so you don't
think that there's some funny business
going on
let me
open up here the terminal i'll clear
everything i'll run the command
and once
the install is complete in a package
json we'll see react router dom package
and as far as the setup
here's what we want to do
we want to go to app js and you know
what let me start this one up so npm
start
and we want to import three things we
want to get the browser router which is
going to connect
to the actual browser
the routes component which is going to
be a parent
for all our routes and then route
component
which we'll use to set up a single page
so let's go there let's start setting up
the code and then i'll talk about the
props and the rest of the stuff so let
me first navigate to app.js
like i said we want to grab three
components now eventually you'll also
get a link
and some other ones as well but for now
these are the ones that we want so
browser
router
route
and route
and as a quick side note if you want
you can add browser router in the
index.js basically where you wrap the
whole application but in my case i'll
settle for app.js
then we want to go with react and then
router down
and like i said first we want to connect
to the actual browser so we'll go with
browser router then we'll set up the
route component
so let's go here with route and then we
need to set up those
single routes and basically the idea is
following where we go with route then we
need to go with path
so this is going to reflect whatever we
have in the url
and when it comes to the home page we
have
special syntax where we go with forward
slash
now in this local setup that forward
slash means localhost 3000
in production
that is going to be whatever is your
domain whether that is udemy.com or
youtube.com or johnsmilk.com and
hopefully you see where i'm going with
this
so this is special this forward slash
but basically where we have the path
we'll set up
whatever url is going to be here in the
url bar so for example if i want to have
a page by the name of testing then
instead of forward slash i'll type path
equals to testing and if i want to set
up a nested one let's say i want to go
with products and then forward slash
info then yes you guessed it one of the
ways how we can set it up is going with
products here and then forward slash
testing and if you're a little bit iffy
on that don't worry as we cover more
examples
it's going to be easier to understand
that so first let's go with path forward
slash again that means our home page and
then we want to go with element and at
the very basic level we can just pass in
the code directly here in the element
and in the upcoming videos we'll see how
we can use components for that but at
the very basic level we just need to set
up here what we want to see on the
screen so in my case i'm going to go
with simple div here and i'll say home
page like so so let me close out the
route component and once we save we
should see homepage i'm with you so that
is my home page and like i said now
let's set up
some dummy page and i'll call this
testing so instead of forward slash
which
is a syntax for the home page i simply
go here with testing now if i'm gonna
write about then of course
in the url i'll have to type forward
slash about now if i have testing and
you guessed it i'll go with forward
slash and testing and one i want to
display here well let's make this one a
little bit more complex just to showcase
that of course we can set up whatever
logic we want over here so i'm going to
go with
div and then inside of it i'm going to
go with heading 2 and then the testing
let's save it and eventually of course
there's going to be a navbar and all of
that cool stuff but for now yes we'll
have to do all the navigation
in the url bar so let me navigate there
and what is the page name well it is
testing correct so we go with forward
slash and then testing once we navigate
there check it out now we have our page
and if you want to go back to the home
page you guessed it we just need to go
back to the local host
3000 so again we install the package we
grab three components browser router
route and route browser our connect to
the browser route is going to be a
parent for all our routes
and then for every page we'll set up a
route component with two props a path
so what is going to be the url
and then what we want to render we pass
into the element not bad bad we created
our first pages
life is great but you would have to
agree with me that when it comes to any
realistic application hard coding
the
page content in app.js is probably not
going to be very good on your health
you'll just end up screaming at your
computer
so here's the thing
we can also pass in component directly
so path
setup stays the same again whatever
we'll type over here will match in the
url bar so if it's forward slash then
it's home page if it's about hopefully
you see where i'm going with this
but when it comes to element we can pass
here the component and therefore you'll
find
in the pages
bunch of components again
the only reason why i set them up
is just so we can save a little bit of
time
on setting up the boilerplate so for the
most components you'll just find this
section with the class name of suction
so in here we just add a little bit of
css and you can take a look at it in the
index css and heading 2
with about
so these are the pages
that we will have
in our project
so here's what i want to do
i want to go to app.js i want to import
them all
so for now just home about and product
notice all of them are coming from the
pages and as i know
of course you don't have to
name your folder pages
it can be anything
it can be banana pudding
and also there's nothing special about
these components they're straight up
components the only difference is that
now we will use them in the app.js and
we'll pass them into the element prop
and as a result
whatever we have
in the component
will be the content of the page
and yes in those components
you can import another component which
also is something we're going to do and
as you can see as a result
it's going to be
easier to manage your application
instead
of hard coding everything in the app.js
so let's try this one out where i want
to go to
app.js and i want to import
three components and lastly
if you want to set up here index.js and
that is your preference where basically
in the pages you import all of the
components and then export them you can
also do so but in my case i'll just go
the long route where i'll say import
then home and then that one is coming
from
and now i'm looking for the pages folder
more specifically on one let me copy and
paste here
let me just change a few things around
where i want to go
with a about one
so let me select that one
and we also want to go with the product
so let's go here and let's say
product
and once we have all of the imports in
place
now let's keep the path forward slash
again this is going to be for the home
page
but
let's change it around for a testing one
where i'll remove it first
and i'll actually pass here the home
component home
let's close it it's also necessary and
check it out now we have that item too
let's copy and paste and let's just
change it around where it's going to be
about
and this one will be product
and when it comes to path in here we'll
say about
as well as product and again we can test
it out if we navigate to url
and then if we go with forward slash
about check it out now we have about
page now
you can probably already guess that if
i'm going to go to products we'll
navigate to the products page so that's
how we can set up our page content
as components
again we set up most likely a folder
since there's going to be multiple pages
and we just set up straight up
components there's nothing special about
them they're straight up components the
only one that has more info on here is
the login one but we'll talk about this
one a little bit later once we actually
get there
and whatever you set up over here
whether that's bunch of other components
coming from other folders and all that
will be the content of the page and as a
result it's easier to manage your entire
application all right and up next let's
take a look at how we can navigate
around our project because at the moment
the only way how we can do that is using
url bar and that is probably not the
best user experience
unlike
the traditional multi-page application
where we use
the href
the link element in this case if we want
to navigate around our project so
internally we want to grab the
link component from react router dom now
if we want to go somewhere externally
for example
if i want to go to google.com or
johnsmilk.com then yes you still need to
use the link component like so so you'll
set up a link component href and then
whatever the url
but in order to navigate around our
project we'll use the link component
instead
and then the link component is looking
for one thing it's long for
to prop
and then notice we just pass
in the url
now again we don't need to go with full
url
in here we just need to go with forward
slash and then whatever we have in the
app.js
so since i have these pages forward
slash so the home page about and product
kind of makes sense if in the home page
if i want to go to about page i need to
go with forward slash and then the name
is about now these ones do need to match
so make sure that the syntax is correct
so in home.js
i want to set up a link to above just
right after the heading 2
and then in the about js i want to set
back the link
to the home page so let me try this one
out
where
first i guess i'm going to go to the
home page
so let me navigate to the pages
then we're looking for home js then we
want to get the link one so import
it's a named imports a link from react
router dom and then right after the home
page let's go with link two and again if
i want to navigate to product i'm going
to go with forward slash product now if
i want to go to about i'm going to go to
forward slash and about
and let's add a name
so whatever we want to display here and
a little bit of styling therefore i'm
going to go with class name
and i'm just going to say
btn so once we save notice now i have
this link to the about page now we
navigate to about without that full page
refresh
and in order to make this a little bit
more interesting why don't we also do
the same thing in the about so then
we'll be able to go from one to another
one so let's go to
same deal we want to grab the link
import then link probably should have
copied and pasted
but anyway so react router dom right
after the heading two let's go with link
two in this case i want to go back to
the home page
let's say back
home and then let's also add that class
name so a little bit of styling class
btn so now we can nicely go from page
page without that full page refresh
again if we want to navigate around our
project we want to grab the link
component it's looking for one thing and
one thing only it's looking forward to
prop
and in here you want to pass in the same
value
that you already have here as far as the
path
so if you want to go to about you go
forward slash about
and if you want to go to product you go
to forward slash product and hopefully
you see where i'm going with this
okay
but what if by mistake
to use your types
some kind of path that doesn't exist so
let's say i'm gonna go with forward
slash and then hello at the moment
basically we'll display nothing why well
because if we take a look at our app.js
we're only handling these routes we have
forward slash home and about and then
product
and in order to handle
this type of scenario we want to set up
an error page where essentially we'll
display
some kind of error message
for every request that doesn't match any
of our routes
and we want to do that with a route
component we want to pass in the path
with a star so essentially this will
match everything
so if we cannot find those pages over
here
then this will collect all of them and
then we want to set up some kind of
error page so first let's set up this in
the app.js and then we'll work on the
error page now there is already
a page in the pages but i just want to
add a little bit more content so first
let's go to app.js let's copy and paste
and yes we want to place here all the
way at the end because this catches
pretty much everything so we want to go
here with the star and now let's work on
the error page
or essentially at the moment again we
have this section with a class of
section and heading 2 with an error but
i want to set up a link back home and as
i know this is what we're going to be
working on
so we want to get the link component
from reactra or dom we want to add some
kind of logic so 404 page not found and
then we wanna navigate back home
so let's try this one out where in this
case
i'll speed this up i'll grab the link
since we'll need that one
then after the heading two or you know
what let's change this one around where
i'm going to go 404 so page not found
a paragraph page not found
and then we want to go with link
component to
where i want to navigate well i want to
go back home and in this case let's just
say back home let's save this we want to
import the page so let's try out the
auto import
so i'm going to go here with error
and let's see whether i got actually the
page now it doesn't look like it so let
me try one more time yep or here i can
use the auto import and notice now we
have a nice 404 page so if i'm going to
go with forward slash and testing same
deal
we don't have that particular page in
our project
so basically there is no url that
matches that and therefore we display
this error page now if we click on back
home we nicely navigate back home all
right and up next let's see how we can
add navbar and footer to our project
now in this video i'll quickly show you
the most basic approach which clearly
has its limitations since it adds the
same components or elements to all of
the pages but don't worry in the
following videos we're also going to
cover more fine grained approach
where we will nest our pages and set up
the shared layout
and
as far as the basic setup we simply want
to set up the elements
above
or below
the routes again please don't make the
mistake and place the element inside of
it you will get the narrow but if you
place it above or below the route this
will be added to all of the routes like
i said most basic approach but
there's definitely situations
where this is a nice solution so let's
navigate back
and let me go above the routes let me
set up the nav
component basically an element and yes
of course you can set up the component
import it here and also of course you
can add the links now i'm not going to
add the links in this scenario since
we're going to do that in the upcoming
examples and i don't want to repeat
myself and waste your time basically
i'll go here with our navbar
and the same thing we can do with footer
i'll say our footer and once you save
you'll notice that
in all of the pages we have the navbar
as well as the footer if we navigate to
about
same is going to work with products and
it's not going to be surprised if we
navigate to another page
and we get the same result
navbar and footer gets added to all of
the pages so this is the most basic
approach
how we can
set up some shared layout where
essentially in this case we're adding
both of these elements to
all of our pages all right
up next let's add a navbar to our
project
and in the process we'll learn how to
set up nested routes
shared layout and index page
since i want to cover everything step by
step please be prepared to
factor our application a few times
so if i want to nest some routes
inside of the another route
i just need to
go with the parent route so notice
instead of self-closing the home one
i'm gonna go
with an opening tag and the closing tag
and then i just decide
which routes i wanna set up in here
and there's going to be
multiple issues with our original setup
the main focus is that now all of these
routes will be nested inside of the home
one
and basically
they will be relative to whatever we
have
as a path to a home run and don't worry
i'll show you also with another example
just so you can see better again we'll
refactor our application multiple times
so don't worry if in the beginning
some stuff breaks
so let's navigate back to app.js like i
said
i want to nest about product
and the error page inside of the home
one because i do want to set up a shared
layout
and i want to set up also a navbar so
let's try this out where instead of self
closing
let's go here
let's say route and then close it and
i'll send it of course there's a syntax
error like so and like i said
there's going to be multiple issues if i
go to about
i'll actually see the homepage and yes
that is something we're going to fix in
a few videos now the main idea right now
is the fact that these are all relative
to the homepage
and it's kind of hard to see
since this is homepage since we're doing
the setup on homepage so therefore let
me showcase that if i'm going to go here
with
dashboard
instead
right now you'll notice that you won't
be able to navigate to an about page
you'll have to go to a dashboard forward
slash about so that's the key about
nesting routes
where whatever you have here as a parent
will be the main route and then whatever
is inside is going to be forward slash
and whatever path is over here so let me
save it notice we cannot see anything
but if we go to dashboard which is
technically
our home run right now and then about
then everything technically works now we
still
don't display the about one but we'll
fix that in a second so hopefully this
is clear where again in our case
we're using
as a parent our home one
but for example if i'm gonna go outside
of this home one and if i'm just gonna
say okay let me set up the dashboard
you'll see how basically this works
again you won't be able to see
actually
what is displayed in the stats for
example the page that i'm about to set
up but you will be able to see that this
is how it works so element and then let
me go quickly with dave over here i'll
say
dashboard
like so
and then we want to nest this
so let me go here with the route and
then inside of it we'll set up path and
then whatever path i want so in my case
i'm going to go with stat
so now we're looking for dashboard and
then stats so this is how normally we'll
nest routes and again we won't be able
to see this stat div
because we need to add a little bit more
logic which we'll do in the next video
this is just to showcase
how this nest thing is going to work and
if we're going to go to a
dashboard and stat
you'll see that we'll have this
dashboard one but the route exists
so technically there are no issues over
there now if i go to dashboard this is
where i'm displayed and now if i go to
about again since our parent
over here
is the home route that's why we see the
about page again that's the first step
how we can nest routes inside of the
parent route and then whatever we have
for a path
is going to be the main path
and then whatever we set up over here
is going to be the parent plus
this value over here so if you go here
with dashboard then it's going to be
dashboard about dashboard product and
since in our case it's a homepage we go
with about and then product okay
so our initial setup works somewhat all
right where the urls are matching
whatever we set up there with nested
routes but the problem is the result we
keep seeing all the time the home page
so how we can fix that and how we can
also set up a shared layout well we need
to go to the parent in our case
home
and import outlet
the outlet component
and then we just need to display this
outlet component
and whatever we'll set up around this
outlet component is going to be the
shared layout across the pages
that are
nested inside of the parent and then
the actual page content
will be displayed here in the outlet one
and i think it's
going to make a little bit more sense if
we set it up and that way you'll right
away see what i'm talking about so let
me go to home.js we want to grab this
outlet component
and
the position is really up to you
again you'll see once we add navbar that
of course
however you set up this return
that is going to be how your shared
layout is going to look like now i'm not
going to keep this link i think we're
good to go
so i'm going to go with outlet and now
once i save actually i see this home
page so at the moment this will be
shared
all across the pages but i nicely also
see the about page and if i'm going to
navigate to a product
same deal i still see this home page so
this one is shared
all across these nested pages
and
also i see the actual content from the
products page
so now we can put two and two together
if this is shared
all across the nested pages
why don't we set up the navbar
and add some links
and as a result we'll be able to
navigate from page to page from home to
about
and to the product now in order to set
that up we need to go with new component
so i'll set up the components folder and
in there i'll create navbar js and we
want to import a link one
and then let's set up the nav
then let's import that in the home jazz
and again
whatever
return your setup over here that's how
all those pages will be displayed so if
you do decide
let's say underneath the section to set
up a footer you can definitely do so
again this is going to be that
shared layout all across the pages and
don't worry the home page the actual
parent is gonna look somewhat funky
we'll work on that one next so first
let's worry about the navbar
and i want to do that by navigating here
please don't set this one up on the
finals
because it's already there we have the
components so in the source
i want to create actually not a new file
i want to create a new folder component
and this of course also showcases that
of course like i said
in all of the components in the pages we
can use other components because they're
just good all the regular components
i'll set up navbar.js now there's going
to be one more file because i'll show
you the active link as well
but let's not worry about it right now
i'm using this extension
to create my component this is going to
be navbar like i said i do want to get
the link so let me close
the sidebar here i'll say link from
and then i'm looking for react router
dom
and then we want to go with a nav now i
did add a little bit of styling in the
css that's what i'll add here class name
nav bar and then we just want to set up
the links
now i will set up
links for
about
products
and home page but
we might add one more for login one a
little bit later so let's go here with
link to this is going to be to the home
page
and then let's add a text let's copy and
paste
now this one will be to about page again
whatever pages
you have
so in our case we have about
and products as well as the home page
let's set up about
let's set up over here product
and now we want to navigate to the home
one
and import that navbar
so let's go with import
navbar and basically we want to get the
component
and like i keep saying
whatever structure
we'll set up over here
is going to be the result in the browser
so i don't want to keep this section
right now as it is instead i'm going to
go with react fragment since we need to
return one element
then i'll place a nav
the top
after that i will remove this home page
and then let me bring this section
up
so i'll display the navbar like so with
these links
and in here in the section
i will have that outlet
basically
whatever we have inside of the page so
whatever we have in the about in the
product
essentially all the pages that we have
nested
and as a result notice
not only i display
the contents of the about page or the
products page
but we also have the navbar so if you
want to add a footer go ahead
most likely you'll want to do that
beneath the section
and with this in place now we can set up
the index page because at the moment
if we navigate here
nothing is displayed so let's fix that
in next video
all right so our functionality is almost
complete
the only thing that's missing is the
content in homepage
first let's understand why that is
happening in the app.js we have nicely
nested the routes
and
for the parent we have the home and
inside of the home we have that outlet
and there we display product about as
well as the error page something that i
actually forgot to add
last video so if i'm going to go with
hello notice again we'll still have that
nice layout the shared one with the nav
bar and all that
and in here we display the content but
when it comes to actual homepage
well
we don't have any specific content here
that's why we render pretty much nothing
we just have the number and technically
if you want you can add that heading to
or whatever content you want but just
keep in mind that that will be shared
all across the components basically the
pages we have nested so what is the
solution well the solution is to set up
index
routes
and in here i just added some text from
the react router docs
you can definitely read it through but
i think it's going to be faster if i
just showcase the syntax so
if we have these nested routes
for the main one for the parent we can
set up
the index road and it has a special
syntax where we go with route then we
pass in the prop by the name of index
and this will always always always match
whatever we have here for the parent
path so if this is going to be
dashboard
then yes this index is going to match
the dashboard however since in our case
we have home we have home and then again
the same deal we go with element
now the gotcha here is that
we still want to set up some kind of
shared layout correct
and therefore we'll have to create a new
component
and in that new component we'll
basically take whatever we have right
now
in the home one
and we'll add that one as a shared
layout in here as an element
so whatever we have right now in home
we'll create a new component we'll call
this share layout so now
always share this layout
all across these pages but then the home
one will have its own content hopefully
this makes sense so now let me save this
and let me first go
to a
pages
then we want to create a new one
and i'm going to call this shared layout
as always you can call this shake and
bake doesn't really matter let's grab
the home one
and you know what also as
we'll be setting this up we can remove
that section because
each of them have already that
section with a class name of section so
that is an overkill so let me navigate
to shared layout copy and paste now let
me remove this section we don't need it
so now we have only two things
we have layout which will have the page
content whatever is the page the home
page the about page the products page
and also
whatever we want to put it around it so
in my case that is just a navbar
and once we have this one in place let's
navigate to app.js
we want to set up that shared layout
first
so let's say here shared layout and yep
of course it breaks
so let me copy and paste
i'll say here shared layout and now we
just need to work on that index page
so
if we want to set up a page that will
match the parent in this
nested
url structure we go with route
then index and then we pass in the
element so in this case we want to go
with home and now we need to navigate
and first of all we need to close it
here then we want to navigate to the
home one and since the moment i'm
displaying the nav bar
we want to remove some stuff where i
think i'll remove both the lincoln
outlet i don't think we'll need it since
we already have the nav bar anyway and
then we just need to come up with
whatever we want to render so i don't
want the outlet i don't want a navbar i
just want to go with my good old heading
to and i'll say home page and
yes we can also remove this sector like
i said yes i purposely
did this the long way to kind of
showcase how we get to that shared
layout and what issues we're gonna get
along the way so yes there was a little
bit of refactoring the good news is that
check out through our result we have
home page which displays home and about
then products and then if we have some
kind of page that doesn't exist let's
say products and hello then we display
homepage and we nicely
navigate back so hopefully
this is clear
where if we want to set up
this shared layout first we need to come
up with a parent in our case that is
index but again i showed you example
with dashboard whatever you type over
here that's going to be the parent then
most likely you'll come up with some
kind of shared layout so what you want
to share across those pages and as far
as the parent you'll set up the index so
that will be the content only for the
actual index and then rest of the pages
and remember we need to use
outlet to render
those results
all right and before we start working
with url parameters
let's also see how we can set up active
links
and effectively what that means is that
once we're on the page
this link will have specific styling
whatever we want to set up
and in order to do that i will create a
new file just so
this typical setup stays for your
reference
and instead of link we want to grab the
nav link
now what's special about the nav link
is the fact that
in style and also in the class name
we can pass in the function
where there's a property button now
is active again this is provided right
away
by react router
and then based on that value
we can set up
some type of styling again this is
the straight up inline css approach but
we can also do that with classes
and of course we'll take a look at both
examples let's start working on the main
setup first
where in the components let's create
styled navbar
and again
the reason why i'm setting up a separate
file is just so you have right away a
reference for the basic setup let's copy
and paste again we're looking for nav
link instead
let's change these suckers as well
so we're looking for
now the link for now let's not do
anything let's not add any kind of logic
we simply want to navigate
to
app.js
or i'm sorry what app.js shared layout
my bad
and i'll copy and paste and i'll just
say
shared layout
shared or i'm sorry not shared layout
for some reason i'm totally
tripping here so styled and then navbar
of course my apologies and for some
reason i didn't change this one as well
and instead of typical navbar let's go
here with style navbar and once we save
we right away notice
that our active link
gets different styling
and first let's just quickly cover why
is that happening and second
we'll take a look at the code that
controls that so first why is that
happening well again by default if we
use that nav link
the react router by default even without
us doing anything
adds this class of active to it and if
you take a look at index.css
and more specifically if you just keep
on scrolling somewhere around the navbar
you'll find this active class
so if you just set up an active class if
you use navlink the class will be
automatically added and as a result
you'll get these styles so now let's see
how we can control that
code a little bit more first of all let
me close all my files and all that here
so let me start from scratch i think
it's getting quite busy and let's just
take a look how we can add
good old regular css to it so i'm in the
style navbar then we want to go with
style over here and i'm not going to add
to all of them but i will showcase for
the home one so i'm going to go with
style
i want to go with interpolation and like
i said we want to pass here the function
again this function the value and all
that is provided by react router down
now keep in mind this is not just good
old parameter here so don't say is
active we need to specifically look for
object and then is active that's how we
can properly access that and then since
we're setting up here inline styles
we can just use a ternary operator
where we go with a return so whatever we
return this object will be applied to
this link
and more specifically i want to look for
the color
and then i want to check is active so
what is the value
so if it is true i want to add
color red
and if it's not then i want to go with
gray please keep in mind that we can set
up whatever functionality you want over
here i'm just going for straight up
color of course if you prefer setting up
your css in line you can add whatever
the properties with values you want and
now check it out if we navigate to
homepage
the style will be red
so the color of the link is going to be
red and yes if we add this to the rest
of the links it's also
going to work i already set up the
reference for you over here
so in my case
in the style 9 bar i'll just showcase
the class approach since in my opinion
that's probably is going to be something
you will use more often so if you ever
need this reference it's available in
the readme
so let me remove this style here and now
instead of style i'm going to go with
class name
and if we take a look at the css you'll
notice that not only i have the active
one i also have some general
style for the link and yes
of course like i keep repeating you
would normally add more code over here
so instead of
just relying on the active one i'll say
all right what is the value for is
active if it's true then i want to add
link class as well as the active one
basically this is where i'll have more
styles normally
and if it's not then it's just going to
be
link class which just
gives those general styles so let's try
this one out where again we're going for
the function
in the function we're looking for the
object and then we go with is active
and then let's set up
that ternary operator
where we want to go with
is active any node i think in this case
i'm just going to go with implicit
return so is active if it's the case
then i'm going to go with link
and
active and then
if it's not then i'm just gonna go
with link one i do wanna grab this
entire thing
so copy hopefully there are no
bugs there
and then let's just set up on all of
these ones let's save this is going to
be
our default setup and then once we click
now of course we
get that active class as well and as you
saw there's multiple ways how we can set
up
if you just
have the active class it will be added
by default to that nav link so
technically you don't need to do
anything but most likely you'll set up
the class approach also keep in mind
that of course you do have this inline
css option as well most importantly you
have nav link then the function then
object in the object you have is active
and then you can use this value to set
up your logic
all right and now let's see how we can
read url parameters and as a result
we'll have some dynamic pages
and for this i just want you to imagine
a product page where we display a bunch
of product and then once we click on
that one specific product we display it
in a separate page
however here is the key
i don't want to set up
a
separate page for every product that i
have
it makes more sense for me
to set up one page which is going to act
as a placeholder
and then i'll just get the data that i
need to display so that way i can use
the same page for example 4 000 products
or 3 000 and hopefully you see where i'm
going with this
and in order to set up url parameters
you want to go with this colon and then
whatever the parameter name called the
shaken bake call this vegan food truck
in my case since will display products i
just thought it's going to make
more sense if i'm going to go with colon
and then
product id but this name is really up to
you
now as far as this url
this can be straight up like so where we
go with colon and product id this can be
products
stats
and then product id
again this part is really up to you
i just thought that going with products
and then product ready
is going to make
more sense before we begin i also want
to quickly mention that yes
you can set up that nested structure
like we did over here
for a product and product id as well
i just went with this setup for two
reasons first
i really really really want to focus
on the url params and i think
it's gonna be better if we use this
setup so that way it's easier for us we
don't
need to do this whole song and dance and
second i also want to showcase that if
you don't have the shared layout
which in this case we won't you don't
always have to use that approach you can
also use this approach as well where you
go with whatever is the main url and
then in here specifically we go with
this dynamic option hopefully that is
clear so
first
let's navigate right now
to app.js and get that single product so
if we take a look at the pages there is
already a single product just a heading
two
so when we in the object first of all
set it up and i'll do that right after
the product
so let's go with route then path
then
we'll go with a product
and then that product id
and you'll see that it is essentially a
property so again we can name it
whatever we want so
we go with colon product
id and then what is going to be the
placeholder well we want to go with lmnt
and then we want to go with that single
product which hopefully is going to work
but it doesn't look like it so that's
why sometimes this auto import is
annoying because it doesn't work so let
me save this and yes of course i have
the error so let me go here with import
and then single
single product like so and that is
coming from
and we're looking in the
pages i believe right
and then we have a single product so now
everything works we have that single
product and now if we go to url
if we just type whatever gibberish we
want so eventually there's going to be
actual data because i already prepared
for you but let's say if we type one two
three we have single product if we type
i don't know 333 we'll also get that
single product so that's the placeholder
we're going to use
so now let's navigate to the single
product
and let's take a look how we can access
it
so
this is the setup where we go with that
colon and then
whatever
is going to be the parameter name so in
my case product id
now if we need to access it
we need to get the hook from react
router dom so use use params and we'll
also get the link
and then we want to invoke that hook and
notice how this name now
needs to match whatever we have over
here
so as long as they match you'll be in
good shape and then for timing let's
just display it
and let's navigate back to the
main product page
so let's set this one up
where i don't think i'll need style
navbar anymore
but i do want to navigate single product
like i said we're going to be looking
for two things we're going to
get the link first and also we want to
get that hook use param which is going
to access
those parameters in the url
then all that is coming from
react and yep this is not correct we
need to go with import my apologies not
const so let's go with react router down
then as far as the return
first we want to grab that product id
and you know what as i said note why
don't we do this
why don't we just log the sucker
so let's say your use params and you'll
clearly see what am i talking about so
let's invoke this and then let's
navigate to the console and check it out
we have the object um what do you know
we have product id 333 so if all changes
around one two three then of course that
value will be also one two three so now
we want to pull this out from the use
params
from the object so let's go with product
and then id now that is equal to use
params let's invoke it and like i said
let's set up that link
back to the product of course if you
want you can navigate also back home but
i guess it's going to be back to the
products backed product
and then
where we have right now the single
product for time being let's go with
heading 4
and let's display the id
so let's say here
product and then id let's save it and
check it out now we have 1 2 3 again
if all changes around you
four five six
seven
and this is going to be the value so
next video will iterate over the
products that i provided in i believe
data.js
will render all of them
in the products page
and then from there
we'll set up a single product page as
well
all right and once we have the single
product page in place
now in the products.js
let's iterate over the products that are
coming from the data
and then for every item
i want to return an article we'll have
to use the key
since of course this is react and then i
want to access product name as well as
product id which i'll pass into this
link and notice the url again this needs
to match whatever we have in app.js
since in the app.js we have products and
then product id this is where we
dynamically pass in the id property
which is going to be in every product um
once we set this one up then in the
single product
we'll use that id
and instead of
rendering it
on the screen like we have right now
basically pull out that one specific
product
then we'll get the image and name and
then we'll display it now before we
continue let me right away say that yes
normally we'll get this data from the
api or database or whatever
but since i want to keep this nice and
cute that's why i prepared this data.js
which essentially is just an array of
products each product has the id so this
is something you'll see over here in the
url name as well as the image which is
just an external url so these images are
stored
on the cloud somewhere so that way we
don't need to bother with the local
image setup so first
let's go to a product.js
and we want to get the data now if you
want of course you can log it but i'm
just going to assume that it's there and
also we want to get the link
because each and every product will
be wrapped in a link so react router
down then after that let's go with
import then product
from
and like i said we're looking for the
data js
and as far as the return it looks like
for some reason i set it up as a react
fragment
my bad let me just remove we'll have a
section here we'll have a product and
then right after that we want to go with
div with the class of product
so again there's a little bit of styling
over there let's go with products map or
mapping over and then as far as the
return let's go for product again if you
want to log it you can definitely do so
in my case i know
that essentially there is going to be
all of those properties so i want to
return article i do want to add right
away a key
and i'll just say here product id
then i also want to go with heading 5
and i'll say product name
and also we want to set up that link now
i believe previously i mentioned that
we'll wrap it
my apologies we'll just set up the link
here so let's go here with link two and
now remember this is dynamic so now
we are not passing this manually four
five six or seven
we actually go with product
path and then that dynamic id value so
let's go with template string
then product and forward slash and now
let's access that sucker let's say
product
then id
and then inside of it let's just say
more
info
let's save it and this is that single
product so we won't see anything but if
we navigate back check it out
now we have a list of products
title
as well as the link so this is going to
be more info now notice we have this
unique id in two places we have it over
here and we also render it so now we
just need to
add some code to single product
where first i'll grab it okay that's
good but i also want to get the products
from there right from the data products
from
that data
very good like i keep saying normally
this is going to happen
with some kind of fetch request from the
api and all that but not in this case so
i want to get the single product and
that is going to be
with products then use find
and then i'll just say get me the
product whose id matches the product
product here
and then return a product id equals to
product id like so so product dot id
equals to product edit beautiful then
let's pull out image
and name we don't need the id anymore
and then let's set it up in our return
where first we're gonna go
with a heading 5 i guess
and instead of product id
i want to display the name and then
right above it or below it or whatever
let's just go with img
source now will be equal
to that external image so let's set up
the image over here if you want we can
also set up the alternative let's close
the image and as a result we get this
single product and like i said now we
can set up a thousand products
so we can render them in the products
page and then for each product
there's going to be a single product
page essentially which act as a
placeholder will fetch the data about
that one specific product and we'll
render that in the single product page
and now let's see how we can navigate
around our project programmatically
in our case that is going to be once we
submit the form and also let's see how
we can restrict access to certain routes
before we begin though please keep in
mind that normally we will use context
to store our user value
in this case i just didn't see the point
of setting up the entire boilerplate and
we want to start in the app js where we
want to set up
user state value with use state and
initial value will be no
then we want to import two more pages
we want to import
the login page as well as the dashboard
one again the
boilerplate placeholders are already
there and then
in the login one we want to pass in the
function the one that sets up the user
and in the dashboard
we want to pass in the actual user
so let's start in the app.js
where we want to get the use state from
react
so import use
state that is coming from react
and let's set up that state value
so in here let's go with const
user
set user
that is equal to use state and let's
pass in the null
then let's grab both of those pages
so we're talking about
the dashboard
as well as the login one now dashboard
doesn't have anything pretty much it's
the same boilerplate and login has a
little bit more and i'll cover that in a
second now since my auto imports were
not particularly successful let's try it
here where i'm going to go with
dashboard
and again it's not working so i don't
know what's up with that so let's go
with pages
then let's access the dashboard one
let's copy and paste
in this case let's delete
and let's just go with
login
then right after that single product
first of all i'll make
my
browser bigger here
i want to go
above the error one and let's set up
that route
the login one so path will be
login
and then we want to go with element
and let's pass in the login one
and then instead of the login element
let's also pass in set user
is equal to set user so now we're
passing in this function now we do want
to close this one
meaning the route so let's save this
then we'll copy and paste this is going
to be dashboard
dashboard then the component will be
dashboard as well
and instead of set user
go to user so user is equal to user
let's save this
and now let's navigate to the login one
are you not
actually
i also want to add the link to the login
one so not to the dashboard but to the
login one and if you remember that was
in the
style navbar
so let's navigate here and let's add one
more link
it's copy and paste this is not going to
go to products this is going to go to
login and then also the text will be
login let's save it we have the login
once we navigate here
we notice that we have the form which is
awesome
so now let's navigate to the page and
we'll take a look at what we have and
what changes we need to add
so i imported use date i have two state
values i have name and email and i right
away have the handle submit where we
have prevent default pretty much basic
setup
also both of them are set up as
controlled inputs so they are tied to
the state value so as you start typing
you basically will have both of the
values over there now if you want to
test this out let's go with log and then
let's say name
and email again pretty typical setup so
i'm gonna go here with john
john
gmail.com and once we log check this out
we have both of the values so here's
what we want to do
in the login one we want to check
whether both values are there if they're
there first we want to set the user so
this one is coming from the app.js and
yes i purposely went here the long route
and then we want to get use navigate
from reactor or dom and we want to
navigate programmatically to the
dashboard so notice in this case it's
not happening once we're clicking on a
link
or nav link in this case we'll navigate
there using navigate and in order to
invoke that we get to use navigate we
invoke it this is going to be equal to
navigate and then in here we just
provide where we want to navigate and
then in the dashboard since we can
access the user
i just want to say hello and then the
username now we are using optional
chaining because remember initially it's
going to be
no so let's try to set this one up
we're in the login first let's grab that
navigate so use navigate that is coming
from react router down
then i already have the console log okay
beautiful let me remove it
and in here above the handle submit
let's set up that navigate so navigate
is equal to use navigate let's invoke
that and then we're going to go with if
condition so if there is no name or
there is no email
so if one of them is missing then we
want to return and yes that is the check
that i'm going to set up right now so
there's going to be no error messages
nothing like that i just want to check
whether one of them is empty if one of
them is empty we'll simply return now if
both of them are provided we'll go set
user now we just want to grab it from
the params so let's set up here set user
again this is coming from the app.js
like so and first we want to invoke it
we want to go with set user let's pass
in the name equals to name and email
equals the email if you want to shorten
this up of course you can definitely do
so and then let's go with navigate and
where we want to go we want to go to
forward slash
and a dashboard let's save this one
right now
um let's try to do that
with only john so if i just provide one
value notice we cannot do anything or if
i go john
gmail.com
you'll notice that we'll
nicely navigate
to the dashboard one and in the
dashboard i just want to display the
name and the way we set it up if we take
a look at the dashboard we just want to
grab the user since that is what we're
passing in the app.js again
and more specifically i'll look for name
however there's going to be optional
training since initially it's going to
be no
so let me navigate right now to the
dashboard one let me grab the user
and then once we destructure it
where we have the heading 4
instead
i'll say hello
and let's just
access the username like i said optional
chaining and then let's go for name once
we save we have hello john so if we'll
navigate to a login and we'll go with
peter instead and peter
gmail.com
first we'll programmatically navigate
once we submit the form
using the use navigate which we imported
then invoked it and then
we just pass in the path the dashboard
one
and
in the dashboard page we actually
display the name of the user which in
this case is peter
all right and now let's see how we can
restrict access
to certain routes
and first in the pages we'll have to
create that component so in this case
it's going to be protected route and
then in the app.js
you want to wrap
whatever page
you want to restrict access to
in that protected route so yes
in the element you'll have to go with
protected route
and then whatever page you want to
render so automatically this page will
be restricted so let's start here in the
pages
let's set up
new file
i'll call this protected
route for time being it doesn't really
matter what we display
here since the logic is going to change
anyway and once we have the file ready
to go let's navigate back to app.js we
want to go with
protected
route
and then since i want to
restrict access to the dashboard now i
want to wrap the dashboard
with a protected route
and i'll set it up as self-closing
and let's go over here with protected
route
and like i said normally we'll pass in
the user using use context however in
this case since it's right away in the
app.js i'll just go with user equals to
user since we'll need to check it
and then if the user exists
only then
we'll display the dashboard so now
notice
even though technically url says
dashboard we're displaying this
protected route because now we're
wrapping dashboard with protected route
so up next now let's set up the
functionality
where in the protected route we want to
import navigate component from react
router down
and then we want to access two things we
want to access the children so this is
going to be that dashboard page or
whatever page we place in that protected
route and also a user
and then we'll check if the user doesn't
exist we want to use navigate component
and we'll just say where we want to
navigate however if everything is
correct we'll return children in our
case it's going to be our dashboard
so let's go to protected route
and first let's grab that navigator so
i'm going to go here with
import
then navigate so navigate component from
react router down
then let's access
both
props so children's prop
so children and then also user and let's
set up that logic where
if there is no user
then you want to go with return and
navigate to
and i'm just going to go to home page
please keep in mind we can navigate
wherever we want and then if everything
is correct then we'll just return
children
so with this in place
what's going to happen once we refresh
we'll have homepage
and if let's say we try to somehow
manually get to the dashboard the access
will be restricted notice how we
navigate back why well because there is
no user so only if we go to a login one
and add that user mike is john
john
[Music]
gmail.com then
we'll be successful and we'll navigate
to the dashboard and display it and
again i guess the biggest gotcha is the
fact that
in the app.js where you render the pages
you do need to wrap it you need to wrap
whichever page you want to restrict
access to in the protected route
component beautiful at the very end i
just want to set up the
product and product id
as a nested route and this is the case
where if you want to challenge yourself
you can stop the video and try doing it
yourself
so basically whatever we have right now
here with a home page where we nested
rest of the route
i also want to do the same thing with
the product where we want to place a
product
inside of the product we do want to set
up the index one as well as some shared
layout so again if you want to try doing
that for yourself just stop the video
try to solve this puzzle again
basically the setup is exactly the same
you'll probably want to use a different
shared component that's it
so let's start here by setting up that
component so i'm going to go here with
shared
product
and layout
i know it's somewhat long name but we'll
deal with that
then let's grab quickly the code over
here since i don't want to waste my time
on imports and all that so i have here
link i don't think i'll need that what i
want is outlet i won't need the navbar
and as far as the shared layout well
there's not really much that i want to
add over here i guess i'm just going to
take a look at the products one so in
here i just have heading two so let's do
it this way where
we'll go with heading two
we'll go with
products we'll keep that one
and we won't need the import for the
style nav bar as well then let's go back
to our app j yes
we want to grab that long component so
let's say here import
shared
shared
and it was product
product
layout
js so that is coming from the
pages i believe correct so shared
product layout
let's close this and before we continue
in the product js we can just remove the
heading 2
and let's set up the entire
logic here
where first we want to go the route the
path will be products correct so we're
going to go here with product
now as far as the element we'll go with
that
shared product layout let's close this
one
and then in here let's set up both of
these routes
now we can remove the path we can just
say index and for this sucker it's just
going to be
product id and once we save i'll make
this one bigger now and as you can see
the result did not change so the
functionality is exactly the same the
only difference is that now again we're
using this nested routes approach where
we have the parent
we have the shared layout by the way
this is
a tiny typo here so shared layout then
this is going to be our index page which
is our products page and we also have a
single product page
and that should do it for react router 6
tutorial hopefully everyone enjoyed it
and i'll see you in the next videos